hi guys it's silver at again and many
many people actually taught me to start
up themed box to do again and do a let's
play of that again because phase three
came out actually a little while now and
you can now build rollercoasters and
I've literally haven't done anything
with like that rollercoaster stuff and
the importing studio in a very long time
and no clue how I'm going to have to do
this but I'm just gonna see like how
this works okay so I knew that so we've
got four different types of roller
coasters which is very nice now nobody
cares about Aero steel loopers wind
coasters are pretty pretty cool but I
don't know yeah let's let's try and
build an intimate launched coaster I
guess okay nope
wait this is train library oh my god I
am so stupid
in that case closed that's our wait wait
wait wait wait I don't want to station
dialog oh there we go oh I've got wait
wait wait okay I think I get I think I
get it so we've got a train part we've
got an editor we've got the station
which we can only build if we actually
have nodes for the station or the track
and we've got the normal track bar
support so it works like No Limits in a
way that's very interesting you can even
set node properties so I'm guessing
since this kind of works like no limits
that okay I can raise it using shifts no
that's very nice you don't know exactly
how high this is yeah I'd like to add a
station oh thank you that's very helpful
I can already see all kinds of
interesting elements holy [ __ ] comes
with that and comes with a queue and
everything this building really reminds
me of my dutch palace sets which i never
released sorry for doing that but
actually it's really nice this is a
really nice station and we already get a
nice support in there it's not bad
really nice connector actually and look
at that look at that detail wow this is
amazing even get their bolts and the
flanges and everything actually actually
the lighting and detail on this is
not bad so we got all kinds of pieces
now this is what I thought it would be
and this is actually what I wished for
it this is really nice
it works like rct3 in a way as you have
these pieces you can go up and down and
have curved pieces but you can customize
them so if looks yeah that's really nice
I can kind of move this to the side
which I should not do wait
undo that I don't want undo it what you
know what way is that even though that
should have been an undoing wasn't there
that case I'm just gonna delete it I'm
just gonna add another one then so go
straight come on got that okay there we
go
so we get the lift piece and now I
figure I'm gonna have to I thought that
I would be able to get that yellow thing
and lift it up a little so I I've got no
clue how to do this mmm this is clearly
not steep enough but I can only curve it
like that mmm like how do i edit it to
be way I can change the length but
that's not gonna help is it
yes a question is how do I grab that
thing without making it do a curve oh
there we go
are nice that is a bit annoying and
unfortunate in a way fact that you can
grab it and just drag it like that but
it's hard to keep it straight and one of
those a shortcut for keeping it straight
I don't know but anyway yeah this seems
to work
question is can't make it steeper you
know what I'm just gonna delete it she's
gonna take a steeper piece then like
that
okay built that that's better make it a
bit steeper like that you
no it's a launch coaster okay okay so
how do I like what do I then and another
of those piece okay nice it would be
amazing if I actually got to build a
decent rollercoaster without getting any
tutorial whatsoever beforehand because
that would basically prove the fact that
this this game can actually allow you to
make amazing rollercoasters with that
too much of a learning curve okay so
this is really nice you can edit the
length like that you know this is a
decent decent little lift Hill wait now
I'm just gonna change it into that okay
and then build it again and then take
that you know come on no don't do that
Christine is how you wanna make it go
okay so this is straight doesn't miss um
no no no no Oh [ __ ] hell
great just what I want it no need to be
a lift hill thank you very much what are
we doing come on this was not my plan
oh well then here we go again okay so
this works just the length and no do
that and make it go straight like no no
no no no build it okay and now I get it
neat a bit need to do build then use
like the straight piece kind of make the
length small oh nice it doesn't get a
support but I should do those things
manually at some point anyway so that
works it's just a cable yeah this is a
lift piece and then yeah this should
still be the lifts and then make it go
down like that
Oh too steep for me length should be not
shorter I don't know it's headed
straight down or it's like a gentle
slope like this I know I I can
make it more steep ok these are
obviously meant for the curves and stuff
oh wait I've got an idea let me try this
what does this do
that's actually really cool Wow
does it make sense but it's it's
interesting that's actually really cool
like that could work if it weren't for
the fact that's kind of needs a pre drop
then you know what I'm just gonna try
and oh no no no no no don't do that
built that straight piece again like
that good now do a little pre trot thing
what no you don't know you don't do that
what oh my god I'm gonna kill this thing
ok so I've got no clear witness and what
it's doing now but I'm just gonna build
that thing again just the length and no
build and a straight piece thank you
very much for cooperating and then built
that and go down like that thank you
very much
yeah go down like that it straight again
no no no no no wait I keep forgetting to
add that build thing and then build that
and add that sir gorgeous looks like
shits drops aren't even supposed to be
like that but and if I just the length
it's gonna be like that nice I wouldn't
know can I add a small loop no no no no
no wait wait
[ __ ] you forgetting about that ok so
build it then add a loop knots fingers
enormous
that won't work like that make it small
oh [ __ ] work then we're gonna add oops
oh my god why do I keep doing that why
the hell do I keep doing that then we
add okay we built that then we add this
then we built that then we built this
build that do that little airtime Hill
over the queue sexiest [ __ ] there we go
built that okay an hour to find our way
back to the station because this is
obviously the best in terminal looper
ever made even though it's supposed to
be an intimate launched Coast I think
it's not doesn't matter oh god this is
gonna be a hell isn't it right so I need
is a curve like that but not quite I've
gone on do you make it go up again oh oh
oh that's nice oh wow that's really nice
and then can also oh that is very sexy
that is that is very very sexy I like
that I like that a lot
that is so [ __ ] sexy so I can do that
make it go up please
oh wait it already kind of those go up
no it doesn't it yeah so now it goes up
that's really cool so now we add another
one of these no wait we make it like
that build it at that big curve make it
go straight again just the length of it
because I need to get back to the
station no clue how I need to get back
to the station but I'm going to do it
somehow and I'm gonna figure out how to
ride this thing no no no no no do that
build that wait isn't that a bit too big
yeah it kind of is too big oh god oh god
okay so delete that I had that curve
that curve just the length no how do I
get back to the station
like we have a tunnel piece question is
how do I get back to the station
like is there also some kind of connects
thing
okay now this works for curves really
well I can also just grab this node and
move it like that and that is really
really beautiful you can just grab the
nodes move them like that now I see that
this one needs to be a bit low oh wow
this is sexy sexy anything I wish I
could lower it oh my god so what is
where is it like edit thing like edit
node and then oh wow wow so we can
basically lower the ight wide position
position make that 50 oh well well well
that's very low make that 59 I mean no
let's change the to 61 if that makes
sense I think no 62 makes more sense but
then how do I connect these things
that's there that's the problem like
what I can see all kinds of in like
interesting stuff the elements are all
over there
but yeah test coaster
not really first I need to connect these
you're like what oh this looks really
nice question is how do I connect them
no God
Trek dialogue oh god how do i connect
perhaps I can do that connect it to that
thing no that doesn't work okay good but
not really
Yeah right people are probably face
palming right now invisible Trek that's
really nice
let me look up how I can connect it you
know what that's it just just test it
like this I want to see it work
come on test that thing okay it's on the
lift Hill holy [ __ ] nothing slow come on
come on put some pep in your step
grandma
oh my see this is like an intern this is
a pretty much by the looks of its it's a
Togo coaster with an intimate rack slow
lift hill check weird loop check weird
way too big weird drop check the only
thing that this wing misses is a helix
of death but otherwise it's a really
nice toga also why can I not change the
terrains one thing though on a serious
note the shadows yes I love this like
the graphics are still somewhat like
cartoony considering some things and
supports are not the best thing ever but
this looks really good and I see lots of
potential okay so now it's going down
the lift Hill I mean down the drop which
is also incredibly slow what is this
even real time come on what are you
doing there it comes
okay that looks more realistic oh wow
you're going too fast okay so it's going
into the loop nice it probably doesn't
even make the loop oh it just makes it
that's really nice speed over there
why is my camera so slow come on wait to
go over there like okay our time this
hill I mean airtime Hill thing what
would happen if it ends over there oh my
god I need to get used to this
but holy [ __ ] these graphics are awesome
okay so it's just gonna do some weird
shenanigans isn't it yeah that's what I
expected
did it just end up in the station and it
ended up in the station that's really
beautiful so apart from the connecting I
got something done without while doing
research but for the next time this was
just me messing around with the coaster
editor seeing if it works well and if
it's easy to use and my conclusion is
that yeah it's it's easy to use it's
really nice the combination of using
elements like ICT 3 and using well the
nodes and stuff from no limits - I think
there's a pretty much a perfect balance
between that in terms of coaster making
this is really really great in terms of
being foolproof though it's definitely
not foolproof it it's not silver at
proof so it's definitely not foolproof
I'm gonna ask some people like - no no
no I know some people have actually
spent many hours in this game so I'm
just gonna ask them and I mess around
with this game some more before I
started an actual let's play and I'm
gonna try make a real good coaster so
that's gonna happen probably next
episode on the episode after that I'm
actually going to do serious stuff with
this but for now thanks for watching and
thank you Pantheon for actually making
this phase 3 making this coaster editor
and it's awesome it's full of potential
and I can't wait to actually get a mess
around with this some more and try and
get the hang of it